j'aimerais qu'on fasse à tonnay l'abonné
sport pour nos deux invités philippe
candeloro
ce soit l'été ou l'hiver avec des faux
culs
alors ni les rênes de l'émission
de l'émission juste europe il dit il est
collé ben oui
[Rires]
mais pas celle à la main les suisses
monte alors oui alors parce que je ne
sais même pas qui avait un concours de
mister europe bastien cocon donc deux
garçons exact alors qu'est ce qu'ils
recherchent la beauté l'intelligence
j'ai deux un ensemble ah non ça c'est à
dire le gendre idéal le aaa dont vous
êtes le catch est en quelque sorte
qu'aujourd'hui dans la vie des halles
ont en quelque sorte qui sert pas ses
nuits
moi par exemple qui était jean plusieurs
fois dans ma vie j'ai rarement été
idéale spécialité
ouais c'est ça non je n'ai pas toujours
été viré je suis moi-même partie de
pêche malgré voilà de mon plein gré
alors donc vous idéal c'est quoi gendre
idéal bon là ça
c'est un total de qualité par exemple
c'est la bouffe ou pas je puisse unir
[Applaudissements]
non je n'aime pas les gens qui sont
beaux
jeunes ça m'énerve je ne supporte pas
les gens là vous êtes vous êtes de
cuisinier mister europe et c'est
philippe qui a présenté cette soirée non
moi je n'étais pas tout seul avec nous
suisse bodybuilder aussi qui était co
animateur sur la soirée la belle soirée
donc aux 20 cents à récupérer donc son
titre et puis moi j'étais un petit peu
le denis brogniart 2
des lancements des épreuves sportives en
fait durant des épreuves sportives parce
qu'il ya en fait j'ai eu une soirée pour
élire le mister europe leur nation en
2022 et y avait aussi six épisodes qui
ont été fabriqués qui seront diffusés
prochainement ou là tous les jours ils
avaient des épreuves culinaires sportive
donc c'est au delà de la beauté c'est le
remercions pour ça que c'est fait il
soumettrait d'homme parfait voilà c'est
fait c'est pas sur les quelques images
de cette élection on va me répondre
bien sûr on me dit on nous ne reculons
ne vaut rien alors on va regarder
quelques images et après on continuera
de viser ensemble sur ce ce titre de
mister europe
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur l'île de
mayotte qui cette année accueille la
nouvelle édition de mr euros nation 2022
[Musique]
michaud
débat
mais
ses mixes un peu c'est
il mixe que lanka
mix l'homme le plus fort du monde pas
tout à fait c'était un petit peu pour
les mettre en difficulté pour voir
comment ils allaient se sortir de
certaines situations et puis fallait
séduire le jury déjà il ya vécu dans le
joli alors doit le jury avait des locaux
a été longue journée ça a été tourné à
mayotte voilà donc dans chaque ville où
on allait en fait j'avais il y avait des
jurys qui décernait des points aussi en
fonction des épreuves mais c'est surtout
à celle qu'elle est la présidente qui
est là prêt à s'est concerté avec son
jury du soir pour élire le plus bel
homme en fait de cette aventure vous
trouvé vos le mister europe oui merci à
savoir si vous le permettez à les voir
réussir regardez les bien foutues quand
même en fait ça quand on avait un temps
c'est normal moi même j'étais comme
[Applaudissements]
parfois pourquoi quand on a un garçon
pour qu'on se présente un koala ou bien
on à la miss france qui l'a par exemple
mais pourquoi on veut se présenter à un
concours de garçons pour être élu
benjamin a mis d'accord et oui mais il
ya un bus à impériale et si on va
laisser rep ah oui un but moi c'était
plus pour découvrir une nouvelle
aventure parce que j'avais fait un
concours en suisse où ça s'était pas
très bien terminé pourquoi parce que je
n'ai pas gagné ah oui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il ya mister france aussi geek est un
concours e10 équivalent de miss france
n'ont pas beaucoup ça veut dire pour
aller à mister europe tu as dû être
mister france n'ont pas eu ou non alors
mois déjà de bonnes je suis suisse donc
c'est un peu compliqué de faire une
liste heures france d'accord à bardon
oui donc tu t'étais mister suisse alors
avant
défi de jeu je crois que le titre de
mister europe voilà c'est
forcément au mini dans chacun des pays
qui ont été rappelés
fictives pour accéder aux finales
qualification par dans le qualification
donc en fait c'est à dire que n'importe
qui dans les critères si on veut aller
là-bas n'importe qui quand même un avis
dans les critères voilà le france il
vous fait renaître sont de dangereux
pour un live 1 m 80 minimum
80 alors j'ai jamais été bien foutu
alors arrêtez vous êtes très beau donc
il avait 80 faut être plus tôt il n'y a
pas de deux conjoints maximum non ça y'a
pas de revenir en compte ou pas bien
physiquement c'est moi serait que les
miss france ben oui d'accord et quand on
est miss europe on accorder des contrats
de pub on en fait des photos on a ça
sert à quelque chose ça sert juste à se
faire plaisir alors actuellement ça
vient tout juste d'être annoncée
aujourd'hui
on verra par la suite et puis je vous
redis ray chez kate porte une armure
vous revenez quand vous voulez un
sauvegarder tous les cas ce week-end
c'était très beau les très très bien
fait ou et ça m'énerve un peu dire je
n'aime pas lire
c'est mon père toi quel est le plus bel
homme du monde justement parce que toi
tu étais tu viens d'être élu héros mexes
et europe toine le calme ambiant toi c
qui bat mais serena lors c'est le bras
c'est cyril hanouna j'en
sais pas c'est brad pitt c'est bernard
montiel sais qui
vous êtes et vous faire un résumé brad
pitt
appuieront il ya peu j'ai certes mais
toujours vigoureux relation très bien il
ya du choix en tout cas voilà un choix